it has been estimated that as much as 95
of the world's data will never be seen
by human eyes
much of this unseen data is called
end-to-end data or machine-to-machine
there are many sources of
machine-generated data
examples include when the cell phones
ping to the cell towers to check where
they are
when the satellite radio and the gps
connect to locate the car
or your phone the rfid or radio
frequency identification tag readings on
billions of small objects
readings from medical devices and web
crawlers and spam bots perhaps the most
interesting part of the machine to
machine communications
falls under the rubric of the internet
of things
it is estimated that by 2025 as many as
30 billion uniquely identifiable devices
may be connected to the internet
this actually requires a major change in
how the internet works
basically everything will have a chip
and it will be connected to the internet
and they'll be talking to each other
sharing information so when you hear
people talk about smart sensors
in your home or in your city or on your
air conditioning or the smart home
which knows when to turn lights on or
change the temperature or the smart
grids where the city generates and sends
out the electricity
or the smart city itself which
coordinates all of the traffic and the
utilities as a way of being more
efficient and more economical in
providing better service
all of this would be enabled by small
objects communicating one with another
in the internet of things
some of the uses for this can include
putting sensors on production lines to
monitor systems for when they need
maintenance or the smart meters on
utility systems to shut them off at peak
times
also things like infrastructure
management that talks about control and
monitoring of bridges
railways wine farms traffic systems
industrial applications like
manufacturing process controls
supply chain network having predictive
maintenance or integration with a smart
grid to optimize
energy consumption there is energy
management
that's the switches and outlets in bulbs
and tvs and screens and heating systems
controlling ovens changing lighting
conditions
and then medical and healthcare systems
basically anything that's mechanical can
be eventually hooked up and
communicating through the internet of
things
all of which generates an enormous
amount of data as they talk one to
another and coordinate their own
activities
so in looking at the differences between
machine generated data and human
generated data
the most obvious difference is that all
of the machine generated data is machine
readable
it can be immediately searched and read
in mind
it's high on volume and velocity two of
the characteristics of big data
but low on variety which makes it easier
for machines to deal with it
you